hi there its senior editor Kevin van org
standing in for reviewer Nathan Minnie a
to bring you this early access review of
Hawking stunning sci-fi battle escapes
and impressively detailed robot designs
are an attractive wrapper for the fast
and furious flavor of action in Hawken
an online free-to-play MEC shooter that
brings a new level of beauty and
excitement to the mechs onra lots of
mech games do a decent enough job of
making you feel like you're strapped
into a huge hunk of walking metal but
Hawken really nails it hopping into the
cockpit and taking your first heavy
steps into this atmospheric sci-fi realm
is a wild ride as the powerful sights
and sounds that accompany your every
move
help to draw you deeper into your role
as a badass mech pilot it's easy to get
wooed by this Pleasant sensory overload
but pausing for too long to admire your
well-armed ride and the meticulous
detailed surroundings is a fatal mistake
Hawkins firefights move at a fast clip
despite their girth and heft on the
battlefield mechs are surprisingly agile
thanks to fuel power jump jets that let
you sidestep incoming fire leap over
obstacles glide short distances and
hover in place this mobility is great
because it doesn't detract from the
impact of being a mech pilot and it
keeps matches flowing the high energy of
standard free-for-all in team deathmatch
iziz fun in its own right and excellent
for scoring experience and currency to
beef up your mech fleet that said the
grand scope of Hawkins other core modes
holds a very different kind of thrill
missile assault puts a cool spin on
point capture since every turret your
team holds control over continually
hurls rockets towards your enemy's base
siege mode ramps up the spectacle to an
even more impressive scale with longer
matches that involve launching and
annihilating stardestroyer styled
battleships that push across the skies
above the battlefield
aside from being a blast these modes do
a phenomenal job of making your
skirmishes feel like they're a critical
part of a bigger conflict Hawkins sports
some truly impressive in
of maps they sprawl out in all
directions and mix in high vantage
points loads of obstacles to use for
cover and subterranean regions to fight
through their gorgeous - and visually
diverse enough to keep match cycles
feeling fresh the diversity extends to
the wide assortment of mechs you pilot
from light and zippy to big and menacing
there's a mech for all tastes and
fighting styles different handling armor
weapon loadouts and combat roles also
leave lots of room for tactical variety
sinking off foes through the scope of a
long-range sniper mech offers a
different kind of satisfaction from
hopping into an ordnance heavy mech and
Dell using the enemy with clusters of
rockets other specialties and special
abilities are geared towards support
assaults assassination and defense to
round out your options unlocking them
unfortunately can be a slow and somewhat
tedious process if you don't want to
shell out a bit of real cash for bonus
XP boosts or instant unlock access to
speed things along almost everything you
can buy in the game ranging from totally
optional decorations to actual mechs and
weapon components can be bought with
accumulated in-game cash you accrue
through playing matches but even if you
want a little boost to ease the grind
temporary XP and money boosters are
quite cheap on the whole nothing is
outrageously expensive so it all comes
down to a matter of patience and
playtime the sheer time it takes to
build substantive progress across your
mech fleet is a muddy point in an
otherwise excellent game does that have
a huge impact on the overall quality of
the experience not really Hawken goes
far above and beyond what you'd expect
from a mech combat game with impressive
visuals and intense rewarding gameplay
to match
you